Android patterns for performance
Services are an integral part
From all Android apps
But the jobs you provide
Exhaust battery and system resources.
If not,
It may be even more depleted.
My name is Colt McCannless.
And use services in the most effective way
Means ending it in the right way
And sometimes not used.
Services are the way in which an application is defined for an operating system
It needs to run longer
Outside the normal user interface stream activity.
Basically, you can do your business
Without having to wait for input events.
This is great but there are a few things to keep in mind.
First, system-wide services are not free.
Create, schedule, operate and even destroy services
It costs time and memory.
Second, the services run on the UI thread of your application,
Which tries to update the screen every 16 milliseconds or so.
This means that if you are doing a group of activities in a service,
You can easily exceed the 16 milliseconds easily
And drop the frame at the end.
Let me now make this point even clearer.
In 90% of cases, it is the best way to avoid these problems
The service is not used.
But in reality, there are many cases
Where services are used without need.
Including the use of a service to listen to and respond to events,
Is an extreme exaggeration.
APIs, such as BroadcastReceiver, are still available
Respond well to events even when your app works in the background.
It is a multiplier when you continue to use a service
Just to ask a server for data.
This is also a bad idea.
Instead, use Google Cloud Messaging
Allows the server to send updates to you
Which you can still receive in your app directly
Without having to run a service.
And if you know your activity
Will take place in the background,
There is no point in disturbing the framework
To schedule services for you.
Instead, try using a physical thread setting,
Such as IntentServices or HandlerThreads
Or Async Task Loaders,
All of which will bring you the same result with fewer scheduling pressures on the system,
It will also exclude your objects from the UI thread.
This is also an additional benefit.
There are a lot of options available in the framework
To perform multiple types of asynchronous activity
Without the need to resort to the pressures required by the services.
So when possible, try using one of these solutions first.
But if all those options are exhausted
I still find that this service is the only way to solve the problem,
You need to comply with the initial rule of services,
Namely, not to keep service activity more than long-term.
Remember, there are two distinct types of services
They can be terminated in two distinct ways.
For example, the service is running and remains active until it stops clearly
Calling stopSelf or stopService,
Or until your app stops.
Until then, the service remains
Waiting for things to be handled and resources exhausted.
The associated service on the other hand,
It remains operational and consumes system resources
Until all its clients cancel their connection
Calling unbindService or until your application stops.
It is useful to combine these services
But this is a common source of errors.
Such as calling startService
To create your service, call the bindService for an IPC connection.
The problem here is that even when the client calls unbindService,
It will not stop because it is waiting for a stopService call.
The bottom line is that you need to pair the ON and OFF
And bind and unlink directly before the service actually stops,
These are custom with services.
So avoid them if possible.
If you use it,
Be sure to prevent them from working too long.
If you doubt that your services may do so,
The Systrace is a fantastic visual tool
It can help you see where your system time is wasting
And what applications are responsible for it.
This is the main idea for Android Performance Patterns
Make sure you do the right things at the right times
So as not to waste resources or performance cycles.
Check out the rest of the Android Performance Patterns content.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
For tips from other great developers.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.